ils représentent une partie de la
population qui n'en peut plus qui a
envie de s'embrasser qui a envie de
faire la fête et c'est toujours les
mêmes excuses les médecins et vous allez
dire décoller va dire oui vous vous
rendez compte de l'état des hôpitaux
vous rendez compte et c'est bon c'est
toujours les mêmes excuses aussi des
gens qui en ont marre tu as envie de
vivre normalement ça dépend qui ne vise
pas normalement donc laissé le
représenter c'est ces gens là et puisque
les gens le font de ce que tu dis est
bête et autres il y en a marre guillaume
et en corse alors aidons gérald disant
ça parce qu'on fait on demande engendre
éventuellement les en les exhortant de
s'embrasser tu prends des risques pour
les gens aussi fait mais ça fait un an
qu'on dit salah faut passer à autre
chose sait-on jamais sauf que c'est le
concret c'est là donc en fait il est
criminel il est inconscient il est m il
est irresponsable il devra les gens pas
dans les ehpad
mettez vingt personnes plutôt connecter
à n'importe quoi dans la rue pour
reporter une sorte de miti jean paul
hamon vous êtes énervé merci à generali
j'adore quand vous venez sachez le vous
êtes président d'honneur de la
fédération des médecins de france
ouais et président d'honneur également
notre émission sachet de lait mise
images de france les images dont
consiste alors je sais que vous ont
choqué vous êtes énervé mais c'est vrai
que c'est une bonne idée de faire
chanter dans les ep je sens bien et je
serai bien non parce que franchement
honnêtement c'est pas comme si les
réalités pas plein c'est pas comme si la
pandémie était là je comprends que les
gens aient envie de chanter de de se
marrer mais là quand ils sont tous sans
masque alors que là nous on a tous en
train de serrer les fesses en train de
se dire est ce qu on est on est déjà
5000 m en réanimation il y en a plus de
2500 à mettre pour pour qu'on atteigne
le pic de la première vague d'affermir
vague là on avait été obligé de confiner
et où il faut savoir que si on arrête si
on confinait maintenant il faudrait
qu'un jour pour enrayer la pour enrayer
la montée
là on a un sens en 50 mecs de puces en
réanimation tous les jours donc dans
quinze jours ça va faire quoi 1000 1500
plus on va être à 6500 donc 6500 là on
est vraiment au taquet et puis surtout
se dire en tenir compte c'est que les
gens qui bossent sans rien ils
commencent à un peu en avoir plein le
dos il ya des gens qu'il ya des gens qui
se barre avant la première vague on
pouvait faire venir des gens de province
qui venait donner un coup de main des
personnels de province mais là toute
l'airé à son plein les tapis sont ils
sont morts de trouille ils ont ils ont
la peur de venir parce que leur leur
réanimation sont pleines ils ont peur de
dégarnir trop les hausses tôt alors
qu'avant il y avait des gens qui
venaient de l'ouest qui venaient du sud
ouest qui venait à paris ou qu'ils
menaient même
mulhouse là on peut pas et puis ça fait
un an que ça dure donc les gens ils en
ont un peu marre vous répondez quoi ceux
qui disent que qui parle comme francis
lalanne de liberty qui voient leur prix
leur liberté c'est vrai écoutez là moi
je suis venu en moto tout à l'heure
c'était plutôt sympa ça sentait temps en
temps le barbecue en fonte avec les tp
des dehors dans le jardin bon c'est
sympa on a envie de sortir on comprend
bien sûr mais là il faut être
raisonnable on peut bon 6e si vous êtes
dans un grand jardin faut pas le dire à
leurs mains mais vous pouvez être 8 ou
10 à condition que vous respectiez les
aînés les mesures bâle les mesures
barrières que l'on sait que vous fassiez
pas de bisous et c'est là en ce moment
la joie qu'en les joies des gens qu'on
80 85 ans qui admet avoir un consultant
on se tape le co2 bon on se marre bon
les gens ils se marrent à starbucks août
ça peut être aussi sympa de se taper le
coude se faire dès sur des grosses
d'embrassades tout et c'est ça quand
même
le on est pas obligé de jouer au con
comme marie serre comme francis lalanne
c'est qu'il faut condamner chanteur ou
juste voilà leurs clients mais là
écoutez franchement le type il ya une
position bon il séduit des gens dont il
ya des gens qu'il aime c'est bien pour
lui bien sûr hélas les demandes et aux
mecs de s'embrasser alors que là ils
sont déjà sans masque qui sont tout près
les uns des autres
déjà à l'extérieur c'est vrai qu'on a
moins de chances 2-2 chopé le virus à
l'extérieur à condition d'être à
distance et la demander aux gens de
s'embrasser c'est inconscient quoi